Générique
...
Musique intrigante
-La ménopause est encore
aujourd'hui tabou.
1/3 des Français
trouvent ce sujet
difficile à aborder.
-C'est du domaine de l'intime.
C'est pas simple.
-Une difficulté supplémentaire
pour certaines femmes
qui vivent des symptômes
handicapant au quotidien.
-Ca a été un bouleversement.
J'avais l'impression
que mon corps dirigeait.
Je n'avais plus prise.
C'est comme si
je me recroquevillais.
-Mieux informer les patientes
est crucial,
car il existe des solutions
et des traitements.
-Il y a plein de femmes
qui pourraient avoir un traitement
hormonal de la ménopause
si elles le désirent
si nous, médecins, on a estimé
qu'il n'y avait pas de risque
à ce qu'elles le prennent.
-Alors, comment mieux aborder
ce sujet de la ménopause ?
Pourquoi faut-il en parler ?
"Ménopause : la fin d'un tabou",
c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'"Etat de santé".
-Bonjour.
Bienvenue dans "Etat de santé".
Parlez-vous de la ménopause
dans un repas de famille ?
Bah non.
Si vous étiez
tentée de le faire,
sans doute que ça créerait
un petit malaise.
Oui, c'est un sujet tabou.
On va en parler,
Laurence Rossignol.
Merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous.
Vous êtes sénatrice,
militante
de longue date.
Vous avez été ministre
chargée des droits des femmes.
Avant de voir votre portrait,
c'est une question
qui concerne toutes les femmes.
Il faut le rappeler.
-Je suis
ménopausée.
Quand on est féministe,
qu'on s'intéresse
depuis des années
à pousser toutes les portes
des non-dits,
de l'invisibilisation
des femmes
et de leurs conditions de vie,
à un moment donné,
le sujet de la ménopause
apparaît comme étant
probablement un des derniers
gros tabous.
-C'est peut-être pas le dernier,
mais c'est bien de s'y attaquer.
On va en parler.
D'abord, votre portrait.
-Elle a cosigné un rapport
qui alerte sur les impacts
spécifiques du travail
sur la santé des femmes.
-Laurence Rossignol, un tabou,
peut-être pas le dernier,
mais quand même un sacré tabou :
la ménopause.
C'est quasiment
une honte. Pourtant,
c'est pas une maladie,
comme la grossesse.
Mais les femmes
n'en parlent pas.
Pourquoi ?
-La ménopause,
c'est comme les règles.
C'est comme l'accouchement aussi,
en amont de nous-mêmes.
C'est tout ce qui concerne
la santé sexuelle et reproductive.
Ce sont des sujets
dont on ne parle pas
avec d'autres, on n'en parle pas
avec les hommes.
Il n'y a pas de discussion
publique sur ces sujets.
-Même pas aux maris.
-Le mari est un homme,
le plus souvent.
On lui en parle pas.
Ce sont des sujets
du monde des femmes.
Fort heureusement,
dans l'histoire des femmes,
et des silences
dans lesquels elles évoluent,
il y a leur propre parole,
ce monde des femmes,
dans lesquels les femmes
transmettent entre elles, racontent,
et elles parlent
de la ménopause.
Souvent, elles baissent
la voix néanmoins,
même entre elles,
pour parler de la ménopause.
Et donc, c'est un tabou
pour toutes les femmes.
Ca l'est de moins en moins,
parce qu'on parle plus
des règles aujourd'hui.
On pousse une porte
qui arrive sur la ménopause.
-La ménopause,
c'est un cycle
dans la vie des femmes,
où les hormones ont
quand même un énorme rôle.
Infographie :
qu'est-ce que la ménopause ?
-Au fil des cycles d'une femme,
le nombre d'ovocytes
dans chaque ovaire,
qui était d'un million
à la naissance,
diminue jusqu'à s'épuiser.
A la ménopause,
les ovaires cessent
de produire les hormones
de la reproduction :
les oestrogènes.
Or, les pouvoirs
des oestrogènes
sont nombreux
sur les tissus du corps.
Ils régulent
la pression artérielle,
en améliorant la paroi
des vaisseaux sanguins.
Ils préservent le tissu osseux
et cérébral.
Ils sont un effet
anti-inflammatoire
et antioxydant
sur le cerveau.
A la ménopause,
les femmes perdent donc
leur protecteur hormonal
et sont plus à risque
de développer
des maladies cardiovasculaires
ou de l'ostéoporose,
une pathologie 2 à 3 fois
plus fréquente
chez les femmes ménopausées
que chez les hommes du même âge.
En parallèle,
la baisse des oestrogènes
et d'une autre hormone,
la progestérone,
peut fréquemment
provoquer des symptômes,
comme des troubles du sommeil,
des bouffées de chaleur
ou de l'irritabilité.
Alors que 87 % des femmes
présentent au moins un symptôme
de la ménopause,
plus d'un tiers considère
le sujet comme tabou
et ne savent pas
à qui en parler.
Il ne faut donc pas
hésiter à consulter.
-Tout le monde ne vit pas
la même ménopause.
-J'imagine.
-Mais il y a des femmes
pour lesquelles ça devient
un énorme handicap.
Presque...
Je disais que c'était pas
une maladie,
mais ça a des effets
sur le corps des femmes
qui parfois
sont très importants.
La dépression, par exemple,
peut être causée
par la ménopause.
-Ce déficit d'informations
sur la ménopause
fait que les femmes
commencent à constater
que leurs règles s'espacent,
qu'elles sont moins abondantes.
Elles voient qu'elles grossissent,
qu'elles s'empâtent.
Certaines ont des bouffées
de chaleur. D'autres non.
Il y a de la dépression
qui accompagne la ménopause.
Comme par ailleurs, ça se situe
aussi à un moment de vie
qui, indépendamment de la ménopause,
peut être un moment
compliqué,
un moment où il se passe
des choses bouleversantes.
C'est parfois l'âge auquel
on perd ses parents,
l'âge de la ménopause également.
Les femmes ne savent pas
attribuer
à la ménopause
ce qui lui revient
et ce qui revient
aux conditions extérieures.
Elles se débrouillent seules.
Elles savent pas
à quoi l'attribuer.
-C'est difficile aussi
parce que c'est perçu
comme une porte d'entrée
dans la vieillesse.
Avec cette idée
que si on ne peut plus
se reproduire, avoir des enfants,
la sexualité est morte.
-Alors, je pense
que c'est plus ambigu
que ça.
Pour beaucoup de femmes,
le fait
de ne plus être fertile
est aussi un soulagement
et une liberté.
La vie des femmes
consiste souvent
à éviter les grosses.
Plus de règles
et plus de fertilité,
c'est quand même
une libération, un soulagement.
En même temps,
le regard social
à l'égard de la ménopause
est un regard social de...
de mise au rebut.
Une femme ménopausée
est une femme
qui, en fait,
n'est plus sur le marché.
La vie des femmes est terrible.
On passe 35 ans de notre vie
à se faire traiter de pute.
Et au moment où ça s'arrête,
on se fait traiter
de vielle ménopausée.
C'est dur,
la condition des femmes.
-C'est bien de le rappeler.
Certaines ne veulent pas
réhabiliter la ménopause,
mais visibiliser,
lui donner de la visibilité.
Plus on en parle,
plus on dédramatise.
Regardez ce reportage
d'Alexia Léperon
sur ces femmes qui veulent
sortir la ménopause du tabou.
Musique rock douce
-La ménopause, ce n'est pas un tabou
pour cette influenceuse.
Elle en a même fait
son sujet de prédilection.
-Je parle de ménopause
vu que le sujet était pas abordé.
Je trouvais que ça
assez révolutionnaire
de m'afficher comme ça.
J'ai cru qu'on allait
me lancer des tomates en disant :
"Dégage, la vieille."
-Pourtant, c'est un succès.
Son Instagram
menopause.stories
compte aujourd'hui plus
de 22 000 abonnés.
Autour de textes,
d'informations, de photos,
Sophie vient brise
un tabou sociétal.
-Ce que je voulais,
c'était casser des barrières.
J'ai toujours dit que mon but était
de dé-corseter la ménopause,
de la sortir de la prison
dans laquelle elle est enfermée.
Cette image,
la prison, pour moi,
c'est cette image pesante
de l'enfermement,
de la petite mort
avant la vraie mort,
"déjà, ça y est",
l'enfer des femmes,
l'obsolescence programmée,
la date de péremption.
Voilà, on n'en est pas là.
-Ce combat pour changer
l'image de la ménopause,
Sophie le tient
de son histoire personnelle.
Lorsqu'elle est ménopausée,
elle a du mal à comprendre
ce qui lui arrive.
-Ca a été un bouleversement.
J'avais l'impression
que c'est le corps qui dirigeait.
Je n'avais plus prise.
C'est comme si je me recroquevillais
complètement.
J'ai compris que ça touchait
beaucoup l'émotionnel.
J'avais envie de pleurer.
J'étais très fatiguée.
J'étais complètement abattue.
Là, je me suis dit :
"C'est violent, quoi."
-Face à ses symptômes,
elle tente d'en savoir plus
et cherche des informations
sur Internet,
sans succès.
-Aujourd'hui,
quand on cherche
des informations
sur la ménopause,
on tombe sur des définitions
très froides et cliniques.
On tombe, pardon,
sur des définitions des symptômes,
diagnostic...
Voilà, des occurrences comme :
"les 3 phases de la ménopause",
"quel âge ?", "quels sont
les changements du corps ?",
"comment donner envie de faire
l'amour à une femme ménopausée".
Quand je lis ça,
je me dis que la ménopause,
c'est une maladie.
C'est une maladie
qui est en plus dégradante
puisque je reçois "comment donner
l'envie de faire l'amour
"à une femme ménopausée ?".
Du coup, je comprends
pourquoi on n'en parle pas.
Comment peut-on aborder
cette nouvelle étape de vie
de manière fraîche
et décomplexée
quand on te dit direct
que, globalement,
on n'a plus envie
de te faire l'amour ?
-A force de creuser,
Sophie est devenue
une experte de la ménopause.
Comme elle,
une nouvelle génération de femmes
tente désormais
de mieux s'informer
sur cette période de vie.
Comme ici, à Jeen,
un centre spécialisé
sur la santé gynécologique.
Sophie y est invitée ce jour-là
pour parler ménopause
à d'autres patientes.
-Bienvenue. Donc bienvenue.
Moi, je m'appelle Sophie Kune.
Je suis...
connue pour avoir, je dirais,
libéré la parole
autour de la ménopause.
On va papoter ménopause
pendant 1h30.
-C'est pas forcément évident
de demander à ses amis
ce genre de questions
au départ.
C'est des domaines
un peu de l'intime.
C'est pas simple.
Même médicalement,
c'est pas simple
d'obtenir une réponse,
une écoute.
(Voilà.)
-Ce sentiment est partagé
par de nombreuses patientes.
Alors, la gynécologue
du centre
aborde les inquiétudes principales
et balaie les idées reçues.
-C'est important de mettre
la notion de symptôme.
Il va pas être marqué
pour toutes,
on n'a pas toutes
des bouffées de chaleur.
8 femmes sur 10 auront un syndrome
de sécheresse vaginale,
c'est le plus hégémonique.
Mais on n'a pas toutes
des symptômes.
On va surtout pas toutes
le vivre pareil. C'est important
de pas se dire :
"Ma voisine le vit comme ça.
"Moi, je vais le vivre comme ça."
Ou, à l'inverse, de pas se sentir
légitime dans son vécu,
qu'il soit positif
- on a le droit
de se sentir libérée,
heureuse et fière
d'être ménopausée -,
et on a le droit aussi
de pas aller bien
et d'aller en parler.
-S'informer et consulter
est primordial,
car ne pas en parler,
c'est risquer de passer
à côté de symptômes
et de problèmes de santé.
-Pour moi, la méconnaissance,
elle induit
une mauvaise prise en charge,
une absence de dépistage précoce
des problématiques
et, également, un confort,
une qualité de vie qui diminue.
Ca, c'est quand même important
d'adresser cette problématique.
-Aujourd'hui, la parole
se libère de plus en plus
autour de la ménopause
grâce au travail
de gynécologues
et de patientes comme Sophie.
Conversations entremêlées
Il reste encore du chemin,
car 38 % des femmes
considèrent encore
ce sujet comme tabou.
-Vous le disiez,
la gynécologue
en parle, il y a 1001 façons,
peut-être pas,
de vivre la ménopause.
Certaines
ne la voient pas passer,
pour d'autres, c'est invalidant.
Il y a un manque d'informations.
Il y a des femmes qui,
arrivées à la ménopause,
disent :
"On ne m'en a jamais parlé,
ça me prend comme ça
"à 47, 48, 50 ans."
-Si leur mère
ou leur soeur
ne leur en a pas parlé,
beaucoup ne savent
quasiment rien de la ménopause.
Je suis quand même frappée
que les médecins généralistes
ne soient pas tous formés
à parler de la ménopause,
s'intéresser.
Vous êtes médecin généraliste,
vous avez une femme
qui a entre 47 et 55 ans
dans votre cabinet,
il est probable
que la ménopause
soit passée,
en cours ou pas loin.
Il faut en parler. Ca devrait être
une des questions systématiques
à partir d'un certain âge.
-Une étude a été réalisée
par l'institut Kantar
pour la MGEN
et la Fondation des Femmes
sur la perception
de la ménopause.
Que doit-on en retenir ?
Voici Clotilde Truffaut,
administratrice déléguée
à l'engagement sociétal de la MGEN.
-C'est un sujet qui reste
un sujet tabou,
un sujet dont on parle
difficilement.
Un tiers des Français disent
qu'ils ont des difficultés
à aborder le sujet.
Pour autant, quand on interroge
les Françaises
qui sont en situation
de préménopause ou de ménopause,
87 % d'entre elles disent
bien le vivre ou très bien le vivre,
ce qui montre qu'effectivement,
il y a un gap
entre, d'un côté, l'image
construite par la société
et puis, le vécu des femmes
et le vrai sujet, finalement,
ce n'est pas tant la ménopause
que le sujet de l'avancée en âge
et de la discrimination
entre femmes et hommes
au moment
de l'avancée en âge.
16 % des femmes disent
avoir déjà caché
les symptômes de leur ménopause
dans leur vie personnelle
ou leur vie professionnelle,
donc pour nous, le sujet,
ce n'est pas uniquement
un sujet de femmes,
c'est un sujet de société,
ce n'est pas uniquement
un sujet médical,
c'est un sujet
de vivre-ensemble.
-C'est intéressant,
ce 87 % des femmes
qui disent bien le vivre.
Vous pensez qu'il y a une forme
de retenue dans la réponse ?
D'abord, ne pas
se plaindre, voilà,
et on serre les dents ?
-Je suis très surprise.
Bien sûr,
elles vivent avec,
elles ont des troubles du sommeil,
mais ce n'est pas
le handicap absolu,
ce n'est pas invalidant,
elles ne sont pas obligées
de se mettre en arrêt maladie
pour passer
la ménopause,
mais elles serrent les dents.
-Absolument. Ménopause et travail,
on parle beaucoup,
on en a parlé, d'ailleurs,
dans "Etat de santé,
du congé menstruel
qui a été adopté en Espagne,
on en parle en France.
Il faudrait un congé ménopause
ou pas ?
-Avec mes collègues
sénatrices
de la délégation
aux droits des femmes,
on a fait une enquête
sur la santé des femmes au travail
et on est arrivées,
bien sûr,
sur les questions
d'endométriose, de règles
et de ménopause et ce qui est
remonté de notre travail,
c'est que c'est un moment
que les femmes...
Où les femmes sont...
moins énergiques, moins productives,
c'est plus difficile pour elles
et elles le font
dans une indifférence
absolue,
d'abord parce qu'elles
ne le disent pas
et puis, ensuite, parce que
leur environnement de travail
n'est pas du tout adapté.
Je pense que c'est intéressant
de savoir s'il faudrait
étendre le congé menstruel
à la ménopause
parce qu'elles ont besoin aussi
de se reposer,
elles sont mal au travail.
C'est intéressant.
-Il y a des troubles du sommeil
qui sont presque communs
à toutes les femmes
qui ont une ménopause,
il y a beaucoup d'effets
après, de densité variable,
mais...
-Et puis, une émotivité
qui est très forte.
-Une sensibilité exacerbée.
-Elles disent : "Je ne savais pas
pourquoi je pleurais."
Dans le travail,
quand on est trop émotif,
c'est parfois difficile.
-La bonne nouvelle,
c'est qu'il y a des traitements.
Alexia Léperon est allée
à l'hôpital Saint-Joseph à Paris,
qui organise
des ateliers ménopause
pour mieux former les femmes
aux traitements qui existent
et les aider, évidemment,
dans leurs symptômes. Reportage.
-Depuis qu'elle est ménopausée,
Nathalie souffre
d'un symptôme bien connu :
les bouffées de chaleur.
Elle vient s'informer
sur les traitements existants
lors d'un atelier ménopause
organisé dans cet hôpital...
mais elle a des réticences
à prendre des médicaments.
-L'idée de prendre un médicament,
ça va être problématique
parce que
pas assez d'informations
sur ce que...
Ce qui peut être modifié
au niveau du corps, justement...
et à quoi sert
ce traitement.
-Comme elle, de nombreuses femmes
se méfient des médicaments
et notamment
du traitement de référence
dans la prise en charge
des bouffées de chaleur :
le traitement hormonal
de la ménopause
ou THM. Tout est parti
de cette étude américaine
publiée en 2002.
Les chercheurs interrompent l'étude
car le THM causait une augmentation
des maladies cardiovasculaires
et des cancers...
sauf qu'en réalité,
ce risque était surévalué.
Selon cette gynécologue,
on sait désormais
que l'étude était biaisée.
-C'est des patientes
qui avaient
63 ans en moyenne,
donc des patientes plus âgées
que celles à qui on peut proposer
un traitement hormonal
de la ménopause en France
et c'est des patientes qui étaient,
dans 60 % des cas,
en surpoids. Ca aussi,
c'est un facteur de risque
de faire des cancers du sein
ou des risques thromboemboliques.
-Malgré cette mauvaise
interprétation,
l'étude prend de l'ampleur
et conduit à une chute
de la consommation
du traitement
de 50 % des femmes avant l'étude
à seulement 6 %.
Certaines femmes
passeraient donc à côté
d'un traitement efficace.
-Il y a plein de femmes
qui pourraient avoir
un traitement hormonal
de la ménopause
si elles le désirent.
Si nous, médecins,
on a estimé qu'il n'y avait pas
de risque qu'elles le prennent,
si c'est nécessaire,
si les symptômes sont invalidants,
il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui pourraient en avoir besoin.
Madame *** ?
-Oui.
Bonjour. Rebonjour.
Suivez-moi.
-Alors, lorsqu'elle rencontre
des patientes comme Nathalie,
le Dr Chelon
prend le temps
d'en expliquer les risques
et les bénéfices...
-Pas d'hypertension,
de diabète, de cholestérol ?
Non...
Voilà, on va pas faire plus.
-Car il faut quand même
prendre certaines précautions.
-OK, on peut faire ça.
On aime bien
pas avoir trop de distance
avec le moment
où il y a la ménopause
et on n'aime pas trop
après 60 ans.
Il y aurait des examens à faire
avant de discuter
de l'instauration d'un traitement,
si c'est vers ça qu'on va.
Une patiente
qui a plus de 60 ans,
qui est à plus de 10 ans
du début de la ménopause
ou qui a un terrain particulier
familial cardiovasculaire
ou même personnel cardiovasculaire
ou des habitudes de vie
avec tabac, surpoids,
des choses comme ça, on a peur
d'être négatif dans la balance
bénéfices/risques.
Est-ce que
ça vous intéresserait,
un traitement hormonal
de la ménopause ?
-Peut-être déjà
faire les examens
et puis, après,
en fonction des examens,
pourquoi pas tester ?
-OK...
-Grâce aux arguments
de la gynécologue,
Nathalie a donc changé d'avis.
Elle n'est plus complètement
opposée au traitement.
-De toute façon,
je vous retrouve
à la fin de l'après-midi.
-Très bien.
-Mais le traitement hormonal
n'est pas la seule option
pour se sentir mieux
s'il s'avérait qu'elle ne pouvait
pas le prendre.
-A tout à l'heure. Vous pouvez aller
dans la salle d'attente.
-Cette sage-femme propose
une solution plus douce :
l'hypnose.
-Bonjour, mesdames !
-BONJOUR.
-Cette cascade sous laquelle
vous avez envie de vous...
...installer pour...
sentir l'eau qui ruisselle
sur votre corps.
-En visualisant une sensation
de rafraîchissement par l'hypnose,
il serait possible de maîtriser
ses bouffées de chaleur.
Selon cette étude américaine,
les femmes expérimentant l'hypnose
auraient vu une baisse de 75 %
de leurs bouffées de chaleur.
-L'hypnose en particulier,
avec ce message,
on va dire,
envoyé à l'inconscient
dans l'état de conscience modifié
que génère l'hypnose,
va permettre d'induire
des changements.
-Merci de vos conseils.
-Eh ben, je vous en prie.
Musique douce
-L'hôpital Saint-Joseph
est l'un des seuls à proposer
une journée entière
dédiée à la prise en charge
des symptômes
de la ménopause.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Au revoir. Bonne soirée.
-Mieux informer les patientes
est primordial
quand on sait que 7 femmes
ménopausées sur 10
souffrent
de bouffées de chaleurs.
-Ca vous parle,
cette affaire
de traitement.
Ca a été très dommageable
pour la prise en charge
des femmes.
-C'est sûr que la manière
dont les vieux mandarins
de la gynécologie médicale
et de l'obstétrique
se sont rués avec une joie sauvage
sur cette étude américaine
pour en déduire
qu'il fallait arrêter
ces traitements,
qu'ils allaient donner
des troubles cardiovasculaires
ou des cancers du sein
aux femmes qui les prenaient,
ça a attiré mon attention.
C'est comme si
c'était tellement bien
que les femmes
ne puissent pas avoir un traitement
qui va leur permettre d'être déjà...
D'amortir les effets
de vieillissement de la ménopause
parce que ça a aussi
cet avantage,
le traitement, ça a un effet
extérieur, physique,
et puis surtout, ça permet
de libérer des inconvénients
de la ménopause et il a fallu
beaucoup de travail
d'autres gynécos
et obstétriciennes
pour dire : "Attention,
ces études américaines
"ne sont pas les...
Applicables en France,
"elles ne sont pas exploitables
en France.
"Elles sont biaisées
et elles ne sont pas pour nous."
Et encore aujourd'hui,
encore aujourd'hui, on rencontre
de nombreuses femmes
qui sont restées sur l'idée
que ces traitements
seraient dangereux pour elles
et qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas les prendre,
mais on a un autre problème,
c'est qu'on a une recommandation
de la Haute autorité de santé
qui, je crois, date de 2014
et avec mes collègues,
dans notre rapport,
ce que nous demandons,
c'est que la Haute autorité de santé
revoie sa recommandation
parce qu'elle est
très inspirée
d'une grande prudence
à l'égard de ces traitements
et que la Haute autorité de santé
réexamine cette recommandation.
Vu ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui,
est-ce qu'ils écriraient
la même ? Si non,
il en faut une nouvelle.
-Laurence Rossignol,
pour conclure,
est-ce qu'il faudrait trouver
un autre nom à la ménopause ?
C'est perçu si négativement,
c'est tellement stigmatisant
pour les femmes,
on se pose la question.
-Je ne sais pas quel mot
on pourrait trouver qui rende
la chose joyeuse...
Joyeuse et guillerette.
Il faut plutôt
admettre que la ménopause
fait partie
de notre vocabulaire.
C'est un mot médical,
un mot scientifique,
il dit les choses
il faut l'accepter,
ce n'est pas un vilain mot.
-Les hommes d'abord.
Et si eux parlaient
de la ménopause ?
-Si on parlait d'eux aussi,
de ce qu'ils ne veulent pas dire ?
L'andropause, ça existe.
-Ca peut aussi être un angle
sous lequel
on pourrait dédramatiser.
-Leur refus de prendre en compte
la ménopause n'est-il pas
une façon de mettre le silence
sur leur andropause ?
-Voilà, la question est posée.
Messieurs, vous pouvez répondre.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pour parler de la ménopause.
Je signale
que ma consoeur
Claire Fournier
a mis sur les réseaux un podcast
qui s'appelle Chaud Dedans,
un podcast consacré
à la préménopause
et à la ménopause.
Témoignages
des experts aussi
pour ce programme
qui est dédié à toutes les femmes
de plus de 50 ans,
mais les hommes aussi
peuvent regarder.
A très vite sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...